this thing's going to get ugly and
somebody behind closers right now you
know what's happening behind closed
doors okay would you say the taliban are
aspirational people yeah you think
they're ambitious yeah you think uh i if
and if for us if our heroes name your
heroes whoever your heroes are we talked
about it the other time arnold
schwarzenegger let's just say arnold's a
hero for some people that are coming up
maybe not what he comments he made this
week but let's just say arnold's a hero
to some people some michael zero to some
people say reagan's heroes say john f
kennedy's a hero these are some heroes
to people right okay
who is out of those 75 000 taliban take
the top 1 percent most ambitious people
who's that one percent hero they all
love osama bin laden
yeah there it is bingo when i grow up
that's not changing whether we're there
or not there's not about no it's not
really
really i disagree
let me ask you here's a question for you
let me ask you
trump gets on a radio with rush limbaugh
and says if iranian does anything in f's
with us
do you remember that yeah what he said
what did iran do
when when when when uh trump killed
soleimani what did iran do
they bombed pretended
[ __ ]
they didn't do [ __ ]
nothing
go ahead do something yeah there is
something said i'm sorry no people
feared
your leader yeah there's a part of that
that's healthy
mm-hmm
it's healthy
not because we're going to do nothing i
sat next to mike tyson i'm interviewing
him i felt his energy
that if something went down
he's going to whoop would somebody say
he's going to fight a lion
no he would sleep with two tigers every
night okay it was what he said he had
five tigers right but the point i'm
trying to make to you is
people
like to be around other
men or women who are respected and
feared
countries need to have a little bit of
that okay so the point is when you're
saying what's going to happen with these
guys ah isis was quiet under trump
isis was quite under trump you have to
you have to know certain things like
this
you know
this this this almost and i've said some
things about trump some trump followers
are not fans of me and they'll say well
pat this pat that
listen it's moments like this where
people sit there and say
listen that churchill guy man he's
pretty you know i don't know about
churchill but
there's any guy that can go up against a
guy like hitler it's probably churchill
he can probably pull it off it's times
like this where people are sitting there
saying
you know i don't like that guy i can't
stand him i'm a democrat
but when he was there isis was quiet
nobody was doing anything i wonder how
he would have handled this they may not
say publicly but there's like let's
actually play the game let's play a game
here's a game for you okay here's the
game for you trump's president
he goes one more term afghanistan
taliban what does trump do right now
first of all does trump do the exit the
way that uh biden did it
i don't know he did it how biden did it
but he has been calling for an exit
event
so he said it publicly it's not for this
exactly but i tell you how does he do it
look if you're exiting this place there
there had to have been a cleaner plan
than this if the taliban this
intelligence failure
right now
right now if this happened what does
trump do right now i think he says
if the if they are going this course he
would say something to the effect of
uh we're going to be pulling our people
out if any of you [ __ ]
touch any of our bases any of our people
are trying to leave we're going to rain
down crazy hell and fury
the taliban would believe him i actually
do okay that's what i'm trying to tell
you yeah sometimes but we'd still be
leaving is my point no we we'd have a
safe exit that's not the point listen
you're right we would be leaving but
nobody fears our current president
nancy pelosi says we are watching you if
you do something to the woman and the
girls what the what are you talking
about we're watching you okay
we talking about we're watching that's
not how life works threats don't work
that way bro
we're watching you no it's times like
this it's times like this when you sit
there and say
yeah i get it maybe during peace time i
kind of maybe i don't want trump during
peace time but i'm not going to lie to
you during wartime i kind of want a
badass guy like that right now
during war time because if if let's just
say 9 11 happens this year what are the
american people going to be saying
say say something happens 9 11 this year
what american people going to be saying
and by the way who becomes a hero
overnight
of course it is so so
i said this a while back i said when a
girlfriend
say girl dates a guy like me or like
let's just say everybody here at this
table is relatively big and you're going
to make the girl feel safe
say your girl dates a guy like you okay
you're two hundred pounds six one what
are you six one six six foot two hundred
okay six foot two hundred okay
and he leaves you for a calvin klein
model she leaves you for calvin klein
again again again five eight 125 okay
dimples all that stuff right yeah she's
at the club
you're there
you guys broke up two months ago she
left you for that guy
craziest brawl takes uh
breaks out
craziest pro
beer is being thrown around this calvin
klein model is standing there oh my god
i get my scratches i can't i'm doing a
photo shoot next week who's she going
and hanging on to to feel safe you or
the calvin klein model hopefully not
gerard and comes over to me the point
i'm trying to make to is biden is the
calvin klein model you are trump yeah i
see what you're saying that's the point
i'm trying to make with you well i think
ultimately what you're saying and this
goes back to politics and election and
we wanted you know wartime
there is a difference between domestic
policy and international foreign policy
for sure so
uh
biden a lot of the reason he was elected
was because look we're going to calm
things down mean tweets mean tweets all
the mean tweets everything that's going
on let's just defuse the situation
and internationally the us's reputation
has certainly been damaged over the last
four years i'm looking i'm talking about
this now you know i'm talking about
polls
talking about
however in the however levels of the
elite however you can't just say a
blanket
can you repeal what you're doing if you
look at u.s standings globally in the
world they'll have
where people viewed u.s under obama as
which people
which people yeah you have to qualify
that there are a lot of do we have time
to pull up do we have time to pull up do
you think the people marching through
the the the streets of paris hate trump
right now or do you think macron hates
trump do you think do you think the the
elites hate them or do you think the
people marching through again
pull up the polls anyway
but pull up the polls from the liberal
places and in times of war
you think the world liked trump more
than obama i think are you actually
saying that that's the point i'm trying
to his point is the point they didn't
like because they couldn't have their
way with them i'm not even i'm mutually
mutually and you're talking about
governments you're talking about
governments i'm talking i'm talking
about the world overall sentiment liked
obama more than trump i don't think
that's a dispute simply say that public
that's not that's not the just say
international perspective obama versus
trump anyway my point is this back to
your point in a time of war
things change clearly right yeah but you
know that statement doesn't carry a lot
of weight
pull up the pole i'm not this is not my
opinion in time of war we literally
talked about earlier
there was only 11 years without war
first of all let me look i run into a
guy okay who's from another insurance
company if i can get your attention kai
you know you do it without the screen
just kind of do it on your own on your
ipad and if you find it put the screen
up
run into a guy from a competitor
and he comes and starts talking to me
and we start talking i don't know who
he's with
and then also he's like a pretty chill
guy like yeah why i said well let me
tell you man where i'm at you have no
idea how much [ __ ] they talk about you
the stuff they say about you i thought
you were like freaking a monster
dude i watch your stuff you're actually
pretty chill guy
i said so why am i a monster well let me
tell you what they told so what do they
tell you about me boom boom boom boom
i'm like it's pretty interesting that's
like a freaking movie star like if i'm
if i'm that scary i'm impressed by my
you know by the characterization of some
of my competitors fantastic great
i'll take it yeah it's a nice little
story you got there
media is why the world hates trump or
anybody
if anybody loves a president is because
the media has convinced the world to
love them or not to love them that means
nothing to me when somebody says
something like that when they say hey
this person's loved or this person's not
not whatever the part about obama that
i'll tell you
is i've never watched an obama interview
leno letterman any of these guys raw
walked away saying
i wouldn't want having a beer with this
guy i think we'd actually have a pretty
good conversation together because seems
like a chill guy has ever been asked a
hard question ever it's not the hard
question part i first go to the
individual now carter
carter's a sweetheart of a man
great man man
man right
but a leader president maybe one of the
worst presidents we've ever had if you
look at carter and that's kind of said
on both sides it's not me saying it or
anybody else has seen it but on paper
his campaign was the right campaign
human rights backfired kind of backfired
in a major way
wartime you need a wartime leader this
is a pretty crazy time right now that
we're facing a wartime guy got a vaccine
done in nine months not a peacetime
president the peacetime president that
was campaigning said he would never take
trump's vaccine that's biden and the
vaccine that got done in nine months
biden's now going out there getting 165
million people to get the vaccine
because a wartime leader put pressure
behind people's back saying we got to
get this thing done fauci said it'll
take 18 months trump got it down to nine
months by working with these
corporations so
people have to realize there's a big
difference again going back to the
saying there's three types of people in
every company there is the visionary
there's the barbarian and there's the
[ __ ] or the son of a [ __ ]
unfortunately in a situation like that
you kind of need a son of a [ __ ] to be
on your side it's kind of what you need
right now because this officially you
gave him so much momentum in
afghanistan to the taliban so much and
they're not going to slow down so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you